how does this whole thing end
uh probably in tears for who yeah
who's crying is everybody crying who's
crying when
so i think there were some of the hedge
funds that were crying initially then
maybe some of the wall street bets
people who bought last
would be crying and then eventually
there's an probably another set of hedge
funds or even the wall street bets
mob and that you know that army some of
them might have broke ranks and then
shorted the stock
yeah so nobody knows so everybody has to
be aware of what's happening in the game
so if wall street vets said hey let's
squeeze these hedge funds because they
have too much short interest
let's all buy the stock then some of
them might have said okay you know it's
not
two or three hundred dollars maybe i'll
join the short movement now that they've
covered and they could have shorted
their in been like double agents so
people have to understand like this
stuff is gnarly and it's a it's a
free-for-all i mean it is a literal
free-for-all
there's a kind of morality like a big
statement that wall street bets made
in terms of like the elites can't just
push us around they can't bully around
but at the same time you know they're
also interested in making money
right yes is uh what's your sense you
said that
some of the people in the wall street
best might have broken off and shorted
the stock sure are they
more interested there was an emergent
like morality that emerged
and said like we're not going to put up
with the centralized leads but
is that going to continue are they going
to fight the power structures that are
bad for society
are they going to now like i mean are
they ultimately going to introduce more
chaos that's going to damage the economy
and damage the world or are they going
to continue being the good guys and
fighting the uh
the the evils that manipulate uh the
market
what's your sense you know it it really
feels like the dark knight series of
films where like
some people just want to see the world
burn yeah i think there is a contingent
of people who just
literally want to see chaos yeah like
you know that contingent
on some of these you know forums who
just want to create chaos right
um so there's certainly that chaos
contingent but i think overall what the
arc will show is
a group of people getting massively
educated you see it in crypto as well
there was like a three-year period where
all of these failed entrepreneurs who i
knew who couldn't
build companies were then coming back to
me
after their companies has failed or
after they gave up or couldn't clear
market raising money with the venture
capital community
and they were doing icos and i was like
i met you before right and they're like
yeah yeah no i'm doing an ico now i'm
like okay
where's your company and they're like
here's a white paper and i was like
this white paper with spelling errors in
it that says you're going to destroy
airbnb because everybody's apartment is
going to be on immutable ledger
yeah like wouldn't that be better in a
regular database that was private and
not public
like why does it need to be an immutable
ledger so it can't change i'm like
not changing the database is a feature
that's that does not seem like a good
feature
and they couldn't explain it they're
like well just people are interested in
icos and there was that ico mania
and what it showed was there's a global
appetite for risk people
want to try new things this is one of
the great things about the human spirit
is one of the great things about
capitalism
you